When it comes to the best villains in the story,
two names are almost always on the
table: Doflamingo and Crocodile.
However, who of the two is actually the better
villain? I think there can only be one clear
choice here, however there is actually a lot more
to this question than you might think. And so,
what I want to discuss with you today is why
Doflamingo is the better villain and why that’s
actually not a bad thing for Crocodile at all. Now
you might or might not agree with this statement,
and so I recommend you watch this video until the
very end so you know what I really mean by that.
Oh yeah and before we get into
it, if you haven’t subscribed
to the channel yet, make sure to hit that
big red button below this video.
If you are interested in storytelling, even
just a little, you will know that within the
long-lasting format of One Piece, Oda has been
referencing events, themes and symbols from
before the time skip, after the crew has reached
the new world, basically on a constant basis.
Fishman Island references Arlong Park, Punk Hazard
mirrors Drum Island and then we come to Dressrosa.
What does this Arc and the main protagonist
mirror from the first part of the story?
As my good friend mr Morj explains in one of
his fantastic videos, there are actually some
interesting similarities between Enel and Dofi,
as both of them have a serious god-complex,
ruling in tyranny over their people in the
believe that they stand above everyone else
and ultimately are taken down by god’s natural
enemy: Luffy. And I definitely agree with this
parallel and believe that Oda has integrated
parts of Enel into Dofi. However, going not
only by the order of pre-time skip arcs, but also
by the vast number of parallels between the two,
the main inspiration for Dressrosa and Doflamingo
was without any doubt Alabasta and yes, no one
ales than Crocodile himself. In fact, the list of
similarities between the two warlords is so long,
that I will move through it fairly quickly
here to not make this video unnecessarily long.
Let’s start with the more obvious parallels and
then move a bit deeper. On the most basic level,
both the second saga of pre-time skip, Alabasta,
and the second saga of post-time skip, Dressrosa,
are about a Kingdom, that is suffering under the
rule of one of the Shijibukai. One controlled by
a crocodile, the other by a flamingo, going
with the animal theme of the warlords. Also
if you’re like me and for some reason completely
missed this super obvious theme until now, here is
a quick overview: Crocodile is a Crocodile.
Doflamingo is a flamingo. Mihawk is a hawk.
Kuma literally means bear in Japanese. Boa
Hancock is of course a boa constrictor.
Jinbe means whale shark in Japanese. And
finally, Gecko Moria has actually two animals.
There’s the gecko, but putting his name together,
Ge-komoria, Komori actually means bat in Japanese.
There, if you weren’t aware
of that yet, now you know.
Getting back to topic, Doflamingo and Crocodile
share a lot more than just this superficial theme.
Both were the leaders of powerful criminal
organisations with a number of devil fruit users,
including a bomber, someone who can change
their weight, someone who can turn their
body into weapons, a power related to art
and someone who can move freely underground.
Both the Baroque-works as well as the
Donquixote family have themed code-names,
one with numbers, the other with playing
cards. As a result, both Mr. 0 and Joker
operated under the façade of celebrated
heroes in their respective countries,
committing dark dealings that contributed to
the countries' deterioration. Both were trading
illegal substances as part of their scheme, Dance
Powder and SAD. And both of them have mastered
their devil fruit powers to high levels, able to
severely distort the surrounding environments.
Both of them at first seem to get decapitated,
Crocodile by Vivi and Dofi by Kyros,
both of them easily avoid any harm
however by displaying their skills.
Oh yeah, and for some reason both of them also
seem to have thing for drape furry coats.
But this is far from all. Let’s move to a
more personal level now. Even from a plot
and character perspective, Doflamingo is clearly
referencing Crocodile’s story line. First of all,
both were present at Roger’s funeral being
inspired to advance their efforts to reach the
top of the pirate world. Both aimed to do so by
first establishing control over an entire country.
However both of them earned the scorn of the
country’s princess. Both Vivi and Viola went
undercover in their respective organisations
to oppose their evil schemes and protect their
father, King Cobra and King Riku. Both of them
see their subordinates as tools to advance their
own goals. This can be seen especially well in how
they treat those who do not perform well enough.
Crocodile completely disregarded Galdinao
and Doflamingo lost any interest in Bellamy
after his failure against Luffy,
exploiting his admiration for him.
And we can take this all the way to
their respective conflicts with Luffy.
In both cases it needed Luffy
to uncover their true face
and liberate the country form their tyranny. At
first, both Crocodile and Dofi seem superior to
Luffy and in both cases Luffy manages to take
them out in the end anyway. Also the way Luffy
destroys Doflamingo's string clone is similar
to Crocodile's defeat, as they both are sent
up to the ceiling and were beaten up by an attack
which involves Luffy punching them multiple times
until the ceiling gets destroyed as they
fall to the ground. And ultimately both of
them not only lost their status as warlords,
but also ended up in level 6 of impel down.
As you can see, the parallels between both
villains are endless and I think it should be
self-evident that Doflamingo is strongly inspired
by Crocodile’s role pre-time skip. So now,
you might say. ‘Well if Doflamingo is just a copy
of Crocodile, doesn’t that make Crocodile the
better villain?’ So let’s talk about why I think
Doflamingo is superior here from a storytelling
perspective. The most fundamental assumption here
is that good writers improve over the curse of the
career. They learn what works, what doesn’t, how
to structure things better and improve characters.
And while for most authors this will happen over
the course over multiple books, screenplays and
stories, Oda has been writing the same story for
over 20 years. And so all of his trial and error
as well as all of his experience and improvement
are visible throughout that same story
line. So as a result I think that Oda made it a
point to revisit Alabasta, that was already great,
and wanted to prove that he can make it
even better. A similar setting, but better.
Similar story, but better.
This doesn’t mean in any way, that I dislike
Alabasta in the slightest. Just the opposite,
the fact that Alabasta was such a fantastic saga
was the thing that made Dressrosa what it is in
the first place. Also as one big caveat here, I’m
strictly talking about the manga here. The anime
adaptation of Dressrosa was in my opinion way
worse than the manga, while the anime did really
well with Alabasta. That being said, Dressrosa
is woven way better into the overall flow of
the story and the overarching events than
Alabasta did. Once it was over, it basically
felt a bit like a hard cut. Similarly, Dressrosa
integrates many of the major themes of the story
little better than Alabasta does. The helplessness
of the Marines in Dressrosa has more weight and
Fujitora’s experience with Luffy happens on a
more fundamental level I think than with smoker,
who’s transition happens over a longer period
of time. Even an admiral could do nothing in
the face of the warlord system, but in
the end Fujitora actually abolished it.
But moving on to the villains themselves,
I think it’s great that Oda made Doflamingo
what Crocodile aspired to be. He wanted to gain
control over the country and build his power from
there. Doflamingo actually managed to do so. He
completely overthrew the king and ruled openly.
As a result, I think that in the final moments
of both battles, the positions of Luffy and the
villain are extremely important to the symbolism
of the arc and time. Against Crocodile, Luffy
is below him and defeats by punching him into the
sky, revealing him as the crook and monster he was
to all of Alabasta by literally throwing him into
the light. Luffy being below him during the final
moments represents Luffy's climb and eventual
triumph over Crocodile as the underdog, recovering
from his previous losses. It is a struggle for
Luffy to punch Crocodile into the open and through
bedrock, further symbolising the barrier Crocodile
has created to protect himself from the public.
Luffy vs Doflamingo on the other hand
contrasts this. Luffy is nowabovethe villain,
symbolically representing that Luffy
is now the one with the upper hand.
Doflamingo has already been revealed to the
country of Dressrosa as the monster he is,
so they are in the sky and being
watched by everyone on the island.
Luffy's final attack against Doffy is a complete
curb stomp, with not much that can be done to stop
it. The ground underneath them being demolished is
symbolic of the foundation of lies the country was
built on being crushed. This is further symbolised
in the techniques Luffy uses to defeat them.
Luffy defeated Crocodile's single attack (Spada)
with a flurry of multiple punches (Storm)
while Doflamingo's multi-pronged attack
(Spider Web + God Thread) was broken
through with one huge punch (King Kong Gun).
I think it is clear that these two scenes are
meant to mirror each other. And so once again Oda
uses all the good he did with Crocodile to enhance
Doflamingo. And so, I think that both Crocodile
AND Doflamingo are fantastic characters. However,
I think that Dofi is superior in the sense that
Oda was able to build on, improve and expand
what he did with Crocodile. Also, I do think
that Doflamingo’s character overall is one
of the most complex in the story so far.
If you want to learn more about that, I recommend
that you check out my character analysis here.
Thanks guys. Peace.